First let's look at how we can reduce
the overhead and marshaling the arguments and the
data copying. Just to jog your memory, marshaling
refers to the fact that the semantics of
the RPC call being made between the client
and the server. It's something that the operating
system doesn't have any clue about. So in
other words, the arguments that are actually passed
between the client and the server, has semantic meaning
only between the client and the server. The operating system
has no knowledge of it. And therefore marshaling is
the term that is used to say, let's accumulate. All
of the arguments that is there in the call
and make one contiguous network packet out of it, so
that we can give it to the kernel and the
kernel can send it out. That's what is being described
as marshaling, and the biggest source of overhead in marshaling
is the data copying that's going to happen, and I'll explain
that in a minute. Potentially, in doing the marshaling, there
could be three copies involved. Where are these three copies coming
aboard? Well, first of all, the client is executing. When
a client is executing a procedure, all the arguments for
the procedure call that it wants to do is living
on the stack of the client. And there is an entity,
we'll introduce this terminology even before, called the
client stub, and the role of the client stub
is to take the arguments of the call which
are living on the stack. And convert it into
a contiguous sequence of bytes called an RPC
message, so the RPC message has no semantic meaning,
and it's just a contiguous string of bytes, which
you can pass to the kernel, and the kernel
can then send it out on the wire, just
like any other message. So that's the first thing that
the stub does, and that's the first source of overhead.
The client stub is making the first copy, from the
stack, in order to create an RPC message. Now remember
that the client is a user program, so it is
living in the user space outside the kernel, and so
this RPC message, which is being created by the stub,
it is pulled off the client's address space.
Which is living outside the kernel. So, this RPC
message is in user space and the kernel has
to make a copy of the RPC message from
the user space into its own buffer, the kernel
buffer. And that's a second source of overhead. The
second source of copy in doing the marshalling of
the arguments. So now it is in the buffer
of the operating system kernel, now the operating system can
kick the network controller and say, hey, go ahead, take
this buffer, send it out in the wire to the
desired destination. And the network controller, at that point, is going
to move the bits from the buffer, which is in
the system memory, of the operating system, into its internal
buffer using DMA. And this is the third copy that
is happening. The copy that is done by the network controller,
using DMA to move the bits of the
RPC message, copied from the user space into the
internal buffer of the kernel. And now this movement
is being orchestrated by the hardware to move it
from the kernel buffer into the internal buffer of
the network controller, so that it can then get
out on the wire. So those are the three
copies involved in marshaling the arguments of the call,
before it can be put out on the wire.
And the copying overhead is the biggest source of overhead
for RPC latency. Now, how do we reduce the
number of copies? Well, it turns out that the third
copy that you're looking at here, moving the bits
from the system memory into the network controller, there's a
hardware action. That is unavoidable, and therefore, we're going to
live with it. Unless the network controller is completely redesigned,
if the network controller is saying, well, I need
to DMA the bits from the system memory into my
buffer. Well, I have to DMA the bits from
the system memory into my internal buffer, before I can
put it all on the wire. Then this third
copy is inevitable so we live with it. But we
would like to see if we can try to reduce
the number of copies involved here. The first idea is,
can we eliminate this copy that is done by
the client stub? Why is that happening? Well, it has
to create a network message in order to send it
out on the wire. As we said. That the semantics
of this call is only known to the client and
the server, and the client stub is taking the argument
and making a network packet out of it. And it
was doing it in user space. And so what we're
going to do is, we're going to marshal it directly
into the kernel buffer. In other words, we've now
moved this stub, the client side stub, from
the user space down into the kernel. If you
can move it into the kernel, then from
the stack a stub can directly marshal it into
the kernel buffer. And so that intermediate copy
that we had here creating an RPC message and
copying it. Again into the kernel buffer is avoided if the stub can
directly work on the stack, and write it into the kernel memory. So what this
means is that, at instantiation time, the client stub is installed inside the
kernel. At bind time, when the client binds with the server at the bind time,
what we going to do is, we going to say that
here is the client stub, please put it inside
the kernel so that, later on, you can use
that in order to do the marshaling. So the synthesized
procedure is installing the kernel for each client call,
so for each client server relationship. We synthesize the
procedure, which is the client's job, install it in
the kernel for use every time, I make this call.
This stub can be invoked to convert the argument
that are living on the stack, into a network
message, and directly put it into the kernel buffer.
So this, obviously, will eliminate. From the two copies
down to one copy because, the intermediate copy of
converting the arguments into an RPC message is now
eliminated. Now, the problem with this idea is that
we're seeing, let's dump some code into the kernel and
that may not be something that is, so palatable. So this is a solution
that's possible if the RPC service that is being provided between the client and
the server, the trusted service and therefore we can trust, who is putting the
stub into the kernel. In that case the solution maybe a reasonable one to adopt.